[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut prendre les eaux excusez nous on
va faire un peu de ménage qui ont touché
par une rafale de bercy avec toi tu peux
toucher toi moi je peux pas ce que
j'allais gérance fraîcheur parce que je
veux pas que ça c'est quoi ça des gants
à - sens à savoir son nom attention
c'est quoi c'est quoi y'a quoi là dedans
h2o h2o a de l'eau le gars c'est le seul
gars qui arrive on va je pèche pas avoir
de lâche 2 aussi vous avez dû hélas plus
que celle - comment de sodium aller
enora malagré c'est son conseil de
classe
petit par la taille grand par le talent
on s'est dit faisons attention attention
enora malagré de touche pas à mon poste
cette année c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux tu peux me suivent le vert
pujadas on va montrer un bout de 7 là
vous sortez la wii voilà moi je suis
ivre de colère
les commentaires de cette émission sont
sexy mais moi ça me fait vraiment pas
des choses que je peux tolérer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on va démarrer par l'appréciation de
capucine à 9
manon et la joggeuse qui se passe il
donc les les points forts des n'aura
donc je trouve que c'est un petit rayon
de soleil dans l'émission c'est une
vraie gentille malgré tout ce qu on peut
croire sur elle c'est vraiment quelqu'un
de très gentil
sinon les copines c'est une vraie
bosseuse bonne camarade pascal rigole
tout le temps à vos blagues à l'est des
sultans de très bonne humeur merci ça
veut dire que en fait je suis pas drôle
vous avez des raisons et c'est vrai
qu'ils auraient une bonne camarade
souvent et heureusement qu'elle est là
parce que elle elle rit beaucoup et même
nom vannes oc de camille elle est là sur
les crédits ne m'avait fait aujourd'hui
tout ça non mais vous parfois je sais
que vous le faites pour faire plaisir ce
qui a fait perdre des points et n'aura
dans ses points faibles c'est sa
franchise
alors ça ça peut être une qualité mais
la franchise je pense que parfois avec
les comment on peut dire les talents du
paf peut-être quand tu fais des
reproches peut-être être un petit peu
plus - rentrent dedans on va dire voilà
peut-être à être un petit peu plus
respectueux
il aimerait y aura la propreté ce prix
vous en foutez être un petit peu plus
respectueux respectueuse envers les
professionnels coupe aph
j'ai mis un joli 6 bon je veux bien mais
non en fait je me suis parce que je veux
que je peux être la dernière bas on veut
pas vraiment à ça faut pas faire ça
alors là même s'il voulait mettre cette
vous mettez cette dernière lau42 moyenne
m et 6 cents
[Applaudissements]
quatre mois à bali
on va passer maintenant à isabelle
morini ce phoque une oreille mené aux
deux bouts de la chaîne alimentaire
le gauchisme oi pa lé féminisme moi pas
elle croit que j'ai pas de conviction
parce qu'on n'a pas l'éclat les
gauchistes au chili oui gauche ismaël
efféminé vous êtes vous êtes de droite
ou de gauche oscille de nulle part je
suis pas gauchiste de droite que de
gauche
quand même mon mode de vie vous vous
dites du tout et bijoux
[Applaudissements]
deux familles si votre mot à mot l'avis
mont athos au pardon merci réaliser il
n'aura quoi des fois que j'ai la
conviction parce que j'ai pas toujours
lui-même et rock band ne trouve
absolument fascinante quand on peut pas
l'arrêter comme un cheval au galop
j'adore la façon dont elle rit j'adore
la façon dont elles bougent
j'adore la façon dont télé dans
l'émission lé met une sacrée ambiance en
plus de ça les super esthétique ça
protège et mieux quand elle est loin d'
plutôt que juste à côté
et puis j'adore quand elle s'emballe en
plus au ski alors vraiment le m'a épatée
par une énergie c'est celle qu'on a eu
le plus c'était impossible de voir
qu'elle en avait jamais fait donc moi je
lui met huit au qatar allez on va passer
maintenant à la laitière pas paraître
nous sommes là pour sembler à la litière
elle était allée est belle et bonne
sortie le décolleté un peu un choix
s'arrête le décolleté allez vas-y madame
alors enora bon se connaît depuis 10
jours et je me souviens très bien
c'était mercredi ans elle est arrivée
vers moi en tendant les bras j'ai cru
qu'elles allaient m'en [ __ ] une passe
que vous avez quand même une voilà vous
avez une réputation de méchantes vous
fait un peu peur quand on vous voit de
l'extérieur puisque je vous connais
encore pas beaucoup et moi je les points
forts c'est que j'admire quand même ce
que vous osez dire j'admire les gens qui
font des choses que je sais pas faire et
c'est vrai que vous y allez c'est moi
j'admire sa mais en point faible
évidemment parfois et je pense que je
vais être le reflet de pas mal de gens
qui sont devant leur télé quand vous
casser alors quand on dit du mal d'une
émission ça va mais quand vous casser
des gens qui ont de superbes carrière
qui ont eu une superbe carrière je me
dis mais qui est laid quoi pour se
permettre de dire ça c'est quand même un
petit peu on essaie apple.fr ce qu'on
peut prévenir leur compte en garde leurs
attaques tête de rongeurs envoyé par
contre la tête de rongeurs donc donc
alors évidemment vous avez compris c'est
mitigé mais je pense que vous êtes
il n'aura celle qu'on adore détester en
résumé donc quatre et demi je vous ai
mis
l'occurrence féminine ils sont pas là
les tirs sépare c'est symbolique
[Applaudissements]
mario est là dans la tronche et ariane
brodier attention fait dont je suis
envahi ce week end les cherry et même de
ce soir envoyez-moi des fêtes de
rongeurs et afrique très drôle vous êtes
avec votre banquier il vous parle et
tout est un moment où fait juste vous
êtes normal vous faites juste une tête
et grâce
vous allez voir et vous allez voir la
réaction du gard oui je le détestais way
fait pas ça quand vous négocier un
emprunt mais je vais tester et envoyez
nous vos plus belles têtes de rongeurs
hashtag tête de rongeurs dès ce soir on
va lancer ça c'est magnifique et est
allé le dépressif gilbert là parce que
là je vous le dis là ça fait ça bien
mais ça fait toujours bien reçus qu'ils
avaient bien comment ufr important pour
vous il vient n'avait jamais été aussi
beau je vous le dis merci
donc c'est bon si aussi je donnerais
avec moi que tout à l'heure je vais
juste vous dire bonjour pour bourrer
merci attention on va passer au magicien
alors dans des choix des connexions
directes va faire dans voiture et qui
devait faire le plus grand cabaret ça
revient entre faut s'armer pas 17 ans
alors je m'entraîne générique parce
qu'il est à vous donnerez votre
appréciation est votre droit d'accord en
fait des petits il exerce magie n'est
d'accord merci vous êtes hashtag
également tête de rongeurs lourdeur
alléger les récollets à caussade fait
possible si vous aimez les coulisses
d'émissions sais que j'ai une oreillette
et je vous jure il me parle pas de
toutes les missions le seul truc qui me
disent c'est avant le velly il me faut
que chaque jour 4 3 mais ça fait quand
même sept ans que je fais cette émission
ça c'est reconnaître le générique que je
vous aime bien je posais une question si
vous avez inventé un concept on lance un
générique après une heure d'émission
c'est quoi le lit des hauts et des bas
on peut virer des gens apprennent non
[Applaudissements]
enora le point forts évidemment c'est
c'est des opinions très tranchées
voilà même si on n'est pas d'accord les
défend contre vents et marées en bonne
bretonne même si elle sait que ça va lui
créer des inimitiés donc elle le fait
donc c'est une vrai courage un vrai
courage intellectuel donc ça bravo et
n'aura pour ça bref
malheureusement un gros point fort même
si je t'aime beaucoup tag est pas faible
un gros point faible c'est tu sais que
je t'aime beaucoup et a un caractère je
cherchais tous les qualificatifs
j'ai rien trouvé mieux qu'un caractère
de merde il a cherché longtemps un peu
soupe au lait et boudeuse râleuse voilà
donc tout ça fait que parfois été pendu
à son téléphone on peut pas te parler
était un peu tu es un peu chiante
voilà même si on t'aime beaucoup voilà
donc ça dont je vais remettre une note
donc je pète une note qui servira un peu
d'avertissements donc je te demande pour
le deuxième trimestre tu peux demander
l'aide de doom et d'autres sortir les
doigts du cul un peu de passion alors je
vais vous dire je vais donner du travail
aux jeunes quatre madame et attend des
dents mais on dit à l'ats temps il est
honnête il vous aime beaucoup et la
vérité je vous donnerai également ma
date les ch'tis rescue squad et nohra il
ya des très bonnes choses sur le
téléphone ce petit peu d'accord après
sur les doigts sur un téléphone je pète
que voilà on peut avoir des a dit
concomitants oui concomitante ont commis
mais je t'aime d'horaires ça va pour
tout délit aide à moi mon cas acquis non
car après mon coeur allait j'ai pas
quand vous supporter que nouvelle
monture canon mais je vais pas le
supporter longtemps résister alors c'est
moi mais là il y en a plusieurs
cette année et nora moi je suis contente
parce que cette année enora tu a mûri il
ya beaucoup mûri vraiment appris à être
toujours aussi percutante à avoir des
avis toujours aussi tranchée mais
néanmoins en gardant sa est ce qui est
extrêmement compliqué à éviter de
blesser inutilement des gens et donc
dans tes propos tu restes toujours aussi
trancher les avis sont toujours aussi
puissant et aussi fort fait et rôle et a
mûri en fait un fruit mais comme toi
même et tu as été pas mal blessé tu as
appris à ne pas blesser inutilement et
ça vraiment c'est vraiment fort et est
un élément important de touche pas à mon
poste est toujours partante pour les
jeux tu participes à la bonne ambiance
parce que tu te marque comme moi et
voilà
et tu mouiller la chemise s'enrichit
sans s'enrichit mort en chine sans
rechigner
en revanche revanche un vrai problème de
discipline
aujourd'hui les camarades tu as tendance
à parler sur les autres parce que quand
tu veux imposer ton point de vue parfois
tu oublies que voilà
les gros mots et nos bons mois j'en dis
quand je vois des serpents mais toi tu
en dis assez souvent tu vois pas tout le
temps des serpents peut-être des
serpents et à côté de benjamin castaldi
à moitié un bon alors vous allez oui et
puis je terminerai ce n'est pas ton
petit problème d'insolence avec le
patron sa tête assez insolente mais mais
mais malgré tout c'est quand même moi je
transformais ça déjà c'est bien ce genre
à bon dieu en choeur non je fais ça
courageux
d'accord vous allez voir vous allez
aborder et pour tout ça je te mets là
bas nous vos plus fervents admirateurs
on ignore l île parce que gilles verdez
votre plus haute note pour l'instant ce
t3 4 4 ont évoqué pour manier les
ricains 4 pour valérie la demi mesure et
laura votre point fort immense et vous
êtes unique
vous êtes une punchline est une
combattante et dans les débats
heureusement que vous êtes là parce que
quand on prend la table d'en face à part
valérie c'est d'une nullité abyssale
pour ça merci merci de relever le niveau
mais c'est vrai kenora ya quand même
énormément de points forts je voulais
les minimiser mais je me suis dit que
vous êtes dit - faites vous êtes
disciples et vous êtes dissiper vous
apportez à vous même votre propre
contradiction
vous dites que vous aimez quelque chose
et le lendemain vous n'aimez plus non
c'est faux ça c'est des folles vrai
lékol a nou d'as vous êtes parfois obtus
quand lyon venant par exemple
nabila vous ne voulez pas sortir de vos
obsessions
non vous avez comme ça des fixes et
apparemment il veut tout loupé son dada
j'avais dit d'ailleurs vous êtes d'une
mauvaise foi terrible oui c'est vrai que
vous êtes en permanence sur votre
téléphone on l'a déjà dit je rajoute pas
ça c'est une longue liste de points
faibles alors enora je dirais quand même
le vous êtes sur la route de la
perfection mais vous êtes très très loin
du sommet c'est un lumineux 4 jean-luc
je veux bien mais aujourd'hui à bon
d'accord ou alors si je suis d'accord
avec l'analyse c'est une nouvelle et
n'aura cette année fait moins
d'émissions et ce qui fait que cela
portait un peu de recul par rapport à
l'émission justement par rapport à ces
jugements
en plus on est heureux d'avoir aussi
amoureuse moi je suis à côté d'elle donc
je regarde de temps en temps ses textos
et jouer à doumé amour qui apparaît
salle a rempli de joie
la vraie mais bon ça dehors je vais
interdire les téléphones à partir de
lundi est ce que vous aimez pas l'amour
simplement mathieu mathieu de phu my
home maintenant il a cédé quote part
faut parfois ça c'est vrai je vous le
jure c'est le producteur qui envoie un
texto je peux vous le montrez ouais mais
c'est vrai ah ouais donc on les garde
pas parce qu'on se permet de communiquer
avec l'arrivée du tiercé lui
[Applaudissements]
alors voici la vérité non numéro en
régie du mordant temps ce ne soit pas
l'argument non non excusez moi non
arrêtons maintenant monsieur delormeau
j'ai danger ici une oreillette a relié à
la production qui dirige déjà envoyé au
cas texto tu sors voilà qu'on
réfléchisse avait pas vu cette vidéo
rien alors que tu crois avais tu arrives
pas sa démission son oreillette
[Applaudissements]
le chef quand il n'est pas là c'est moi
alors ta gueule
m
on est là mathieu benjamin as-tu c'est
vrai que si je suis si je dois partir
c'est dans votre santé sylvain viendra
trembles ont essayé de me refaire le
test sur le boulard
colmarienne
sans lui donner
juste un petit secret de fabrication
devenu combattant mais pas là le chef
s'est tiré moreau bas à moins d'un euro
le voilà c'est lui qui a une oreillette
si l'on est donc ce que son gros point
fort c'est qu'il va aux faitelles a pas
peur d'y aller et son gros point faible
c'est qu'elle va au fait même qu'elle a
pas besoin d'y aller
elle emploie des mots complètement
excessif par rapport à la situation et
un gros gros problème de comportement si
je peux pas voir une seule ardoise 100k
dessine à zz dessus à 36 ans il ya un
souci pour tous âges mais six bons mois
moi c'est pas un secret avant que dans
l'équipe
celle que je détestais le plus c'était
une aura d'ailleurs on va on va pas
trahir un secret on va dire aux
téléspectateurs la vérité vous avez
hésité à venir parce que ça lui aussi
noir absolu à ce que enora je pouvais
pas la saq et je me fais un bouquin ans
que je l'avais payé et nora malgré elle
d'ailleurs
oui et j'ai bien la formule est
effectivement je pouvais vraiment pas la
saq et est maintenant que la connaît il
faut que je différencie deux choses le
procès vrai que ce sont sa grande
qualité c'est sa grande gueule mais ça
son pire défaut c'est aussi sa grande
gueule elle passe son temps à hurler
quand elle veut imposer ses opinions
c'est souvent assez tranché et c'est
vrai que parfois ça change parfois
sachant et non mais si parfois ça peut
ça peut changer
donc si j'avais dû noter en début
d'année j'aurais misé 0 c'est ça by et
maintenant on a avancé et qu'on est
presque à la fin du deuxième trimestre
je met une note qui je suis j'en suis
certain va augmenter encore parce que
au-delà de la grande gueule j'ai
découvert une vraie petite bonne femme
avec un coeur gros comme ça donc je mets
voitures de leurs massifs ma chérie je
vais te dire la vérité je te demande
ensuite de ne pas me tromper car mon
visage c'est mon métier
[Applaudissements]
où
un stade où l'art bien c'est mathieu
c'est une belle phrase merci cimbéton
points faibles tu connais l'expression
retourné sa veste dans ton cas s'est
retourné la veste pantalon le stip les
choses et tout ce qui va avec
jeudi dont je passais le roi des c est
effectivement tu pouvais passer kebbaj à
main avant qu'il arrive il est
formidable tu pouvais passer quelques
avant qu'il arrive c'est pas bizarre
guillaume c'est avant qu'il arrive
formidable je trouve que tu as tendance
à un petit peu a à avoir du courage
lorsque les gens sont pas là et quand
ils sont là le concept vient de verser
le finir ce sont et que chacun éclatent
et meilleur ami ray donc à l'occasion si
je peux peut-être te te trouver une
paire de couilles que dans mon vestiaire
ça te l'a trouvé mon coeur dans ce très
bien et jamais dans cette émission il y
aura de la place pour deux dents cassées
philo dit non mais bon dans wolf
bref donc dans les petits points faibles
un tout petit peu encore yaya jeudi à
tout non non je me suis un tout petit
peu perdu dans l'identité un petit peu
parce que c'est vrai que tu as une vraie
personnalité dans tpm p et après quand
je regarde tes émissions que j'adore
parce que je regarde le val je regarde
vers le poste je veux souvent une aura
complètement différente une coup c'est
le lot boyer adorable et tout ça et du
coup parfois je me perds un tout petit
peu sur tournée de ton identité sur ces
huit là je suis sérieux trois secondes
avec tout le talent tu as maintenant les
points forts et c'est encore plus fort
les points forts des deux bords très
belle tu es grande gueule effectivement
tu oses dire ce que tu ce que ce que tu
penses et parfois aller en face de cyril
c'est pas toujours évident tu est
extrêmement fidèle et ça je dis ça je le
dis aussi à cyril mais à savoir que tu
fais une attelle même si parfois du
temps gueule avec lui ou quoi à chaque
fois que je fais une interview tu le
défends tu es tout le temps là ça fait
sept ans que tu es là je pense tu seras
toujours là pour cyril et que voilà et
que pour le coup tu es très très très
fidèle et pas beaucoup de personnes qui
sont comme toi et dans les petits points
au mois de novembre je ne tire pas trop
mais ça n'allait pas très bien pour moi
j'étais un peu malade et tout ça rien de
très grave mais ça n'allait pas très
bien pu dû pression que je n'étais pas
bien je peux vous dire que la seule dans
l'équipe et je vous aime tous et pas le
problème qui m'avait les textos avec
comment tu vas tu me connais dîner tu
veux que je vois là le seul qu'on va les
textos hyper mignon est la seule qui le
dit pas non plus mais quand elle a trois
secondes alors qu on est crevé qui
rendent chez nous fondant une assoc
pédaler sur un vélo pour des enfants
pour rien ou quoi
et
dira jamais c est notre effort et je te
mets la note de 6
alors valoir des téléspectateurs je vais
donner ma doctrine aura alors enora il
n'aura des chats et gilles merci d'être
là est ce que c'est vrai c'est pas
facile de se déplacer quand on a des
petites jambes et nos races et de mes
plus fidèles à l'antenne comme en dehors
de l'antenne
je sais que même si elle s'énerve
parfois dans l'émission on peut lui
faire une énorme contre t'emmerde pas
tant les repas c'est pas toi de faire ça
mathieu labbé c'est vrai que ça peut lui
faire une énorme confiance c'est vrai
qu'elle est très vicieuse et ça c'est
hyper important dans une équipe parce
qu'elle écoute les autres et elle rit
beaucoup donc ovaldé ottomane de
jean-luc c'est important c'est vrai que
jean luc et l'avoir à côté de vous c'est
vrai qu'elle a elle rit elle est là
voilà elle donne son avis tout le temps
on peut compter sur elle pour ne pas
être sûre d avis middle et ça
franchement c'est formidable parce que
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de donner
son avis si dans touche pas à mon poste
qu'elle sait qu'après elle va avoir des
coups de fil ou des textos d'animateur
ou de production lui disant on va
griller dans tout le métier et elle elle
répond bien sûr c'est déjà fait voilà
donc pour tout ça c'est vrai que c'est
une des chroniques aussi indispensable
voilà à l'émission - c'est vrai que
voilà elle devient en fermant à cette
année mais finalement elle est tellement
indispensable qu'elles ont fait plus que
prévu après les points faibles
le téléphone trop de téléphones et la
prochaine fois que je vois un téléphone
il va finir dans la gueule de la
personne d'un jeune robot téléphone
d'ailleurs trop de téléphones qu'est ce
qu'il ya il est noter les vins gris
ailleurs d'accord vous faites ce que
vous voulez a merdé moi je n'ai pas ces
pratiques
enora téléphone parfois elle parle trop
sur les autres et 3 insolence insolence
l'insolente ça c'est un gros problème
qu'on a depuis sept ans j'en ai parlé
avec madame rouge -4
j'en ai parlé avec monsieur bouchardeau
l'an dernier voilà alors ça si ça
continue et d'insolence ça va être chez
le conseiller à monsieur aviez nous et
ça va chier des bulles carrie d'accord
mais bon
mine de rien elle elle part vite
mais elle redescend très vite c'est
comme tu peux le tyrolien du juste prix
enora pour tout ça je te mets insectes
voilà on va voir écoutons ce qu'a perdu
6 sur 10 5,6 pour les chroniqueurs et
noir accueillent en moyenne de 5,1 donc
capucine aller au bout un petit
avertissement c'est plus un
avertissement de conduire
voilà c'est un avertissement de conduite
c'est pas un avertissement de travail
c'est un avertissement de produite
attention achtung achtung au téléphone
enora ce que vous voulez répondre à
l'essai je m'attendais à un peu mieux de
la part des chroniqueurs n'ont
maintenant je vais vous dire je peux
ouvrir la veille ses sincères mais je
peux vous dire la vérité parce qu'il
vous a émis des traits tous voilà
l'hexagone a été très gentil avec vous
le problème qui a non mais c'est vrai
parce que trop voilà ils confondent et
je vais vous dire les copines je veux
dire ce qui s'est passé avec vous c'est
que je les ai vu tout à l'heure ils ont
confondu la copine et la chronique car
quand je dis la vérité je leur ai dit
les gars vous mettez ce que vous pensez
vraiment et il a baissé lors de mises à
l'emi tout et rien d'autre parce que ils
vous voient plus comme une copine comme
aurillac r d qui travaillent donc je
leur ai dit on fait abstraction de la
copine si vous n'êtes pas avec tout le
monde et on se concentre sur la
chronique voilà alors je voulais
vraiment pas reçus en remercier mathieu
ça m'a beaucoup touché ce qu'eta 10 et
remercié tous les chroniqueurs qui sont
là et évidemment cyril parce que vous ne
défendez toujours parce que vous êtes
toujours très sympa avec moi et que
c'est vrai que j'en met plein la gueule
à tout le monde
ils ont forcément jean subi les
conséquences et si ça paraît rien mais
c'est pas toujours facile donc merci à
vous puisque vous êtes ma famille vous
êtes mes amis merci avec les capteurs
qu'il est vraiment spectateurs j'en
parle même pas sans eux je serais bas
vous serez pas là le seul petit oubli
pas d'accord avec vous je ne retourne
jamais ma veste
j'ai appris à des chaleurs nages dames 1
parce que forcément coton quand les gens
viennent dans l'émission on apprend à
découvrir donc on change d'avis et
changer des vies c'est humain mais je
dirai toujours qu'arthur j'aime by the
savane j'aime pas bisous on n'était pas
obligé de finir comme ça
[Applaudissements]